and then the next day the coach got us
in the ring and he looked at me and he's
like have you ever taken a back bunk
kid and i was like what yeah and he took
my feet out underneath me and kind of
just slammed me to the mat
and in that moment even though it hurt
like hell i was like
oh my gosh i love this like it was just
this
like a really intense connection i had
to wrestling
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the pretty intense podcast is a
pretty intensely
beautiful talented manifester
brie bella of the bella twins they have
i mean they really have an
empire i mean they have the total bella
show with her sister nikki
they came from wwe she has a hair care
line
a wine of course in this interview
you're going to hear about
how well that's possible how somebody is
able to manifest such an empire
and also what's coming next and what's
on the horizon
really how we connected was from a
spiritual aspect a spiritual friend
so then you're gonna also hear about you
know a lot about religion and
spirituality and perspectives and
you know the the pros and cons of it all
in our thoughts how she's able to create
such an empire and such a beautiful life
and have such great perspective to
really
as she would say just smile and be happy
every day
so enjoy the interview how you doing
girl i'm
good how are you i'm pretty good so
skiing i saw you were skiing
wait who's doing this interview right
have you ever skied before
no so i want to get back into it but
with wrestling i just never took the
chance
but i used to do it before and we just
bought a house in lake tahoe
so i want to get like back into it it
just looks so fun
obviously like being in you know which
is might as well like ask about this
stuff but
being in racing like i was never allowed
to either and so
i you know i was laughing this week i
was like man
it's like being a kid again because i
have
never cultivated any other sports
because of what i did so i didn't i
didn't do water sports i didn't do snow
sports like there was nothing
nothing other than racing and so now i
feel like i get to be a kid i'm like
living like a kid because it's all new
so um was it i mean because you started
wwe and like
how were you like 20 so i start at 23
years old i'm 37 which is crazy so
i it's you know what's interesting is i
actually
did diva search i was 22 years old
and it was kind of like um wwe was
going around looking for female
wrestlers and they did this thing diva
search they actually don't do it anymore
and i'll never forget when i heard it i
was like oh my gosh
like this makes sense in my life i'm
supposed to be a wrestler
just because of the characters and the
athleticism you needed to have to fight
in the ring
it just sounded perfect so i actually
dragged my sister to diva search
and she was really mad at me when we
showed up because it looked like a bunch
of go-go dancers in line
but um we were 22 but we didn't make it
like they were like no we sorry you guys
don't fit
and nicole are like we're the only twins
here are you kidding
but um and what happened is i told my
family i wanted to be a wrestler my
grandfather was like
no like you have to get married
have kids like you can't go fight and
um then he got really sick and so i kind
of put
trying to be a wrestler on hold for just
a little bit and then he passed
and then i turned 23 and my sister and i
are like
you know we love you papa we know you
didn't understand it but we're gonna go
be wrestlers so
i kind of just waited then and then
nicole and i went
and even though they didn't want us we
just fought really hard to get in their
developmental program
and then kind of the rest is history
from there what did you
i mean when you fought for the first
time
what was it that you remember that you
thought man this is so badass i love
this this gets me going
i i went to a place called mcdonough
georgia i didn't even know
sorry georgia i didn't know mcdonough
existed i was like
um mcdonough georgia and so we went to
mcdonough georgia there was
a program there called deep south and
deep south wrestling
so my sister and i went and i watched
one of their little indie shows
and i just seen how they were coming out
as these
characters and it almost felt like i
i took it like it was like adult play
time just like being silly
but it was storytelling and i just
remembered this is really fun
and then the next day the coach got us
in the ring and he looked at me and he's
like have you ever taken a back bunk
kid and i was like what yeah and he took
my feet out underneath me and kind of
just slammed me to the mat
and in that moment even though it hurt
like hell i was like
oh my gosh i love this like it was just
this
like a really intense connection i had
to wrestling and
i you know what it was it was thrilling
and there was something different
and it almost made me feel i was a
soccer player growing up
it almost just made me feel like an
athlete again and i loved feeling that
what aspect does it bring out in you
like do you feel like it's like
does it sort of cut into a certain part
of you that's either
competitive or like a little rough or
like aggressive or technical
like what do you where do you get in
with it you know it's
crazy because when i was growing up as a
kid my parents
they were great athletes so they always
wanted me to be an athlete but i was
always drawn to music and arts
but my mom was pretty much like you're
out of the will if you don't
do like do sports so i was i did have a
natural ability
as an athlete like soccer sports came
easy to me
and to my sister it was my natural
ability
where music and art was a challenge um
and i think wrestling almost felt like
home
it was like a natural ability it was
being
i had the balance i had the athleticism
so it was almost like this place inside
that i it
felt easy but then the challenging part
was thinking about the
story lines and what's your character
what's your gimmick name
what is your character going to fill
throughout the match at the starting of
the match the middle of the match and
the end and then where do you go from
there
and how do you leave the fans hanging
that part was the challenging part
but the part i had always craved my
whole life that i never got
and so because my parents didn't want me
to go into music
and to drama even though i wanted to as
a kid so it was weird because
when i took that first back bum the pain
felt at home but it was everything else
that i knew that was coming that excited
me
and i knew i was going to be challenged
and i was so ready for that in my life
i found a fascinating listening to you
talk about how
in wwe you play a role and you know how
you went through
a couple iterations of roles that you
and your sister would play
and that you ended up landing on
the role of kind of what's more natural
to you
is that is that accurate it is and
you know it's funny because i was a
wonderlust
i mean i i felt like kids some of my
friends they knew what they wanted to do
like they went to college they got
degrees some of them didn't use their
degrees but there was still direction
i had zero direction i also went through
and you know my senior year i lost my
high school sweetheart to a drunk driver
so i dealt with death at a very young
age and
he was he was kind of my plan like i was
kind of like okay
he was an artist a musician he was going
places and i was just gonna go with them
and i was just gonna figure it out as i
go and then all of a sudden
january of my senior year i lose him
and it was like i lost everything i lost
my direction i lost my future i lost
like
you know your first love like all of
that and i experienced
pain and all these other emotions so
literally graduated high school kind of
i don't want to say the chip on my
shoulder but with sadness
um with just not giving a [ __ ] and then
it was like
that summer i was like effort i was
living in scottsdale all the time i'm
like i'm going to san diego i was born
there had family there
and i'm just going to figure out life
and i went there just
caring about partying i was a hooters
girl i went to
i dormed at san diego state i went to
grossmont college
and i was just living which was a great
place to be i was loving life
but people are like what do you want to
do what are you going to do and i'm like
oh i don't know i'm making like really
good money at hooters
um i had no idea and until i saw
wrestling which i saw at hooters we'd
showcase the pay-per-views
yeah that's the first time i saw it i
was like
whoa i dig this um this is something i
can get into
and then all of a sudden i came across a
diva search so i kind of felt like the
universe was
it kind of made my path for me and it
started to give me the signs and at a
young age because i experienced losing
bear i was
very young at i was very spiritual young
but i was very open to signs
and so i was kind of seeing them and i'm
like i think this is where i'm
supposed to be going and i it was weird
how
it just connected with me and my whole
family thought i was crazy they're like
you want to be a wrestler like no one
understood it my mom was like
just losing sleep my grandmother was
saying probably a hundred
hail mary's for me like everyone was
just
blown away but it's my sister and i look
at the career we've
you know we we have like we listened to
our hearts we followed these signs
and i made a really sweet life for
myself and i had fun the whole time
doing it
um i i just love that you like played
the role of yourself but you talked
about
signs and so you know
i kind of the reason why we met each
other and had dinner in napa
is because of another girl who you've
known for a really long time
and the whole like sort of spiritual
spiritual aspect of life which i don't
know
people know that side of you that well
or not but
maybe this is the time because you just
said signs and i feel like unless you're
someone spiritual and
tapped in and tuned in you don't notice
those little nuanced things so
do you track back sort of the aspect of
you that's spiritual and that
that part to um like noticing
signs back then or was it or do you feel
like you were spiritual before you
started to see signs
you know i felt for me it's really
interesting because
bear plays a really big role in
spirituality before he was gone
he really opened up my eyes and you know
he
we both came from catholic families but
bear was really
deep he he was like there's something
more than just what the bible
tells you you know you talk about
feeling and he just
knew this and i didn't know if it was
him being an artist and you know they
speak so cute and like they say these
great things
but he did open up my eyes to that world
and then when i lost him
that's when i really started to see
signs and i started to go to
spiritual healers and i was talking to
angel readers and i started to really
dive into this world and i'll tell you
the first time i went
a woman reached out to me and said this
person keeps showing me
a bear and he wants me to speak to you
yeah and this woman like i was like
i'm so sorry but i don't believe this
stuff i i
i can't and she goes just
can i tell you a memory that maybe only
you two would know
would you come speak to me and i'm not
kidding you she told me about this time
i'll never forget it the diamondbacks
won
the world series um so i i had i was in
high school yeah it was our senior year
and bear and i like hopped this fence it
was a this house
downtown there was no one was living
there and we watched the fireworks show
from the backyard
we didn't tell anyone it's like as a kid
you don't go tell her and people that
she told me and i was like okay
okay i'm gonna listen now like i had
goose bumps i immediately just started
blowing my eyes out
and i'll tell you this woman i can't
find her i wish i could
her name was trisha she opened my eyes
at 18 years old to
spirituality but to this whole world and
i started making vision boards i started
to manifest i started to do all these
things
and people at my age like they thought
it was crazy but
this woman really opened up my eyes to
really like bear leaves you feathers
everywhere still to this day
i'll think about him and i'm not kidding
a feather will fall out of the sky
on to my children or on to me or they're
in
i was at a bookstore pulled a book out
and i'm flipping through a book there
was a feather in a book
come on i swear i i swear and like it
gives me goosebumps thinking about it
but i think because i'm so yeah open to
all this
which then it made me open to career
stuff it was more than just then
bare when i started to experience this
for so many years i started to open up
to everything
to what i should do in my life what's my
next step where i should live
and i really think that's how wwe came
to me
and i was also one of those people who i
did manifest i wanted something
that i could naturally do but the same
time i wanted
to be a character i loved acting i loved
all these different things and i feel
like that's how wwe came into my path
is i just kept manifesting really what i
wanted to do my life which was wwe
and i didn't know it what are um what
are some other other any other stories
where you feel like
you know your vision board came true and
you're like look i put this picture up
here of a house and then i lived in it
or
i wanted these i wanted two kids and now
i have them or like did you
do you have any other crazy stories
about manifestations because i think
this is such a powerful aspect of life
that people just don't
think about know how to do and how the
heck isn't this taught in school and
oh i agree you know people my sister and
i are actually very open talking about
vision boards because we know other
people get super uncomfortable about it
and we're like
eff it like we love vision boards like
and we believe in them and
and um i look at my old vision boards
and i'm like
wow this came true this came true i mean
i did i had on there a boy and a girl
which i know people are gonna think i'm
crazy but i guess i i have a boy and a
girl
i i had on there about wanted to
my sister and i wanted to have a tag
match at wrestlemania years down the
road it happened
um and just all these i mean i
wanted to always live in napa valley
here i am um always wanted a wine have a
wine and
my sister and i we had on there years
ago to be new york times best-selling
authors that happened
and it's not like i make these vision
boards and i have
timelines i make these vision boards
knowing it
will come at some time in my life i
don't know when but i started making
vision boards at like
19 years old maybe 20. um my sister and
i just
seen the world and i got to see the
world with wwe i mean wwe's in 146
countries we went to a lot of them
and i got to do it with my sister and so
we were just sightseeing
seeing the world wrestling it was just
so fun but i do i start looking
and um and on there you know i have
things like happiness
and um being a better person like i
don't have just
material things or things about money or
success because success to me is happy
being happy
i have on there like smile and um
you know find the better you today like
different stuff like that
too that will emotionally make me feel
good but
you know my sister and i we i'll never
forget this we were talking to this
woman
and she was she's a you know people
don't know like kind of she speaks to
the other side
you know she doesn't like being called a
psychic she's not that but she's more
like you know an angel to speak to
angels
this is the girl that we is this the one
that i've talked to not no not her this
is someone
i think you would really like she's from
upstate new york and so we
never met in person only over the phone
and my mom came across her
now i've spoken to her i'd say i'm 37
right before i moved to new york so i
was 26
the first time i ever spoke to her at 26
she told me she's like
i just keep seeing this thing with you
and your sister lucy and ethel like
there's gonna be some reality show in
your lives
and i told her i'm like uh like pump the
brakes i'm never doing a reality show
she's like then it must not be reality
maybe it's scripted but there's
something where i see you and your
sister talking on tv
i see people laughing watching the tv
seeing you two
and i'm like it has to be wrestling
because i was really heavy into
wrestling at that time
and she's like it feels different it
feels like your life
and so we never went back to that
conversation but i write everything down
and i'll go back and look and at 29
years old so i was 26
29 years old is when total divas came to
us
and it's crazy because i
remember when it came my sister and i
were like uh i don't know
i don't know if we could do this like
really just put our lives out there
and her and i kept talking about it
talking about it we're like okay if we
do it we got to go full in
like put our whole lives out there we
can't hold back
and i remember thinking i just don't
know if i'm fun to watch i'm like i
don't really do
fun things like i didn't i don't know
and then sure enough we said yes
and then total divas just like really
hit big
and then all sudden i was like anita
this is what she was talking about
and i'll still to this day be like anita
she's called so much stuff
like you know what she told my mom and
people are going to think i'm bonkers
but i don't care
she told my mom like a long long time
ago
because my mom and i were just talking
about this um i had to be at the time
25. um she goes i see your daughter
moving
to california but i see all these fires
she's like i don't know why
so my mom was always like and i was in
and out of california i loved san diego
los angeles i was in new york back in
san diego
and we never really went back to it but
i remember my mom being like you can't
live in california we see
fires anyways here i moved to napa
valley and two days later i'm surrounded
by fires
i just literally i told my mom i'm like
mom maybe this is what
anita saw you know and my mom's like oh
my gosh and
there's a couple other things in that
phone call my mom remembers that are
actually
playing out kind of around this time
and so you know people will roll their
eyes
and i have even family members to
friends who are like uh
but i'm like you know what for me when i
speak to all these spiritual people
nothing but love comes out nothing but
like
good feelings and i'm like why not
and okay half the time some other stuff
okay i take with a grain of salt
but other times there's something there
and i'm like
why not it only makes sense like we're
souls so why can't we
connect with other souls whether they're
living or they're on the other side i
just
sometimes i'm shocked how people can be
so close-minded to the whole spiritual
world
why do you think they are i think
they're scared
i think sometimes that world is scary
and i will say this
i think religion makes people feel
guilty i feel like to them
it's this this um you're connecting with
satan
some way or it's some witchcraft which
it's not it's the complete opposite
um i think sometimes like i grew up in a
catholic family
i think religion's a beautiful thing but
i do think at times it could be the root
of all evil i see the fighting i see
what it can you know brew i love god
i love jesus i love him in a very
spiritual way
um i don't guilt myself feeling if i
don't go to church on sunday i'm
oh i'm a bad person because my church is
in my home
i i you know i prayed all the time i
pray
all the time day and night i'm always
giving thanks i'm always giving love to
them
i don't need to walk into a church for
an hour to fill that i fill it all in
here
and so um i've realized that because
when i've tried to get some of my
family members too they feel like
they're going against their religion and
doing it
and i'm like you're not this is all a
part of it
in some way this is all part of it
i was having a conversation with jay
shetty for a show
and we started talking about um
meditating and tables and altars
and like we both kept avoiding calling
it an
altar because it feels like blasphemous
or like somebody's gonna like
you know well it's not at church but i
mean i i mean
shoot like a hundred million years ago i
became catholic i
was once upon a time married and got
married in catholic church so i became
catholic and
you know like i mean i've gone through
the religions i've gone there i went to
baptist church
um and but i remember back in those days
i was like i
feel like if i don't go to church and
get a message
then it's pointless and i feel like i
could be just as much if not more
spiritual at home
than i can be in a church and so i feel
like that goes towards kind of like
build your build build your church in
your
in your inside yourself like heaven and
hell to me
is like in a state of existence it's
your
it's your it's where you live mentally
it's not like
a place that you go kind of like a
church isn't the place you go to be
spiritual you're spiritual inside of you
i agree and i needed that being on the
road with wwe
sure i i needed my church to be with me
i
there were so many times in hotel rooms
where i was like how do i keep going
like it was either you know the one
thing that
i very quickly learned um at wwe is
tv's tv so you are fighting for tv time
which means
people can be ruthless backstage and my
sister and i
we came in as athletes so it was you
know when you
come in and you're thinking well as a
sports team you work together
championships come that's how it is no
me
and team or there is me and team there's
no i in team
but like there you couldn't do it on
your own and you really like as a soccer
player i understood my
i was center mid and then i'd be right
mid too i knew my
position was important just as much as a
forward and a sweeper
like we understood each other's
positions and we were connected and we
knew if we all worked together
we're going far which you know my soccer
team we did
and with wrestling i quickly learned
that it was a
one person sport even though it didn't
have to be
and soon my sister and i i think rubbing
off on people
showed that when women do come together
barriers get broken
you really get looked at seriously but
when i first walked in that locker room
i'm like whoa like people were ruthless
so i needed my church with me at the
backstage at wwe i needed it on the road
i needed even those moments as a
waitress when people would be awful
it's like i just need to go in the back
and get to a quiet place just to do a
little prayer or just to remind myself
like i don't want to be these people
and so i felt like i couldn't wait till
sunday i needed here now
but you know and it's it's crazy i felt
like because i always had that mentality
and same with my sister
we went through a lot of [ __ ] at wwe but
it helped me really get through it
because there was times we were like how
did you just walk in the back and smile
and i'm like because i'm breathing there
could be worse
i could have woken up that morning and
not woken up and other than that i woke
up and it's like okay let's
go in if i'm going to fight oh my sister
and i are pretty good fighters so
we're ready thank god i mean thank god
for that right that option to be
like that awareness level that you could
access that
because i was i've been talking about
this recently with people where
um you know what is it about
um what is it about
religion that people are drawn to and
not something else and it's like
less accountability right like it's
someone else's fault there's a plan in
place you go
like say something and it's forgiven
it's you know things are left up to fate
and so when you step away from that then
you know you realize that there's more
accountability right manifestation is
kind of accountability
right like building the church in
yourself is accountability you know like
having the discipline to use it is
accountability
and i feel like that is like the
aspect of it that is um
super powerful but also really difficult
for people because i mean i've
experienced that in my own life just
through
my things that i've gone through
emotionally and
in my own world and and man like when
you realize that every
your life is your fault good and bad
i mean you know it all it sounds bad
when you say that like your life is your
fault but then you go wait but i've done
some really good stuff and you're like
that's my fault too
um that's that level of accountability i
think is scary for people
i agree you know what's interesting is
you saying that it definitely makes me
feel
that religion sometimes doesn't allow us
to be human
because if you are human we make
mistakes we're not perfect
but religion makes you feel guilty for
it where spirituality
really allows you to be human and learn
from your mistakes which i always loved
and appreciated i was like
spirituality just lets you live and i do
believe
that's the way god and jesus wants you
to live but sometimes
the bible and people get mad when i say
this but it has existed for so long it's
been
it's been rewritten there's so much
truth to it
but also i sometimes look at it and i go
it was written in a different
time and i feel like if you know god's
love you know it
inside like you feel it and i feel it
and i know it's a very pure
tender sweet caring love you know i
someone one time said to me
they kind of got a little upset because
for a long time i was a vegan then
vegetarian and
i i now i fish and but i
for a while it was like my compassion
for animals and someone was like well
god put animals on the planet for us to
eat and i was like
but not to abuse and they're like but
they're here for us and i'm like well
see
if this is where i have a hard time
because i believe in unity unity a
planet
animal plant human i go but humans we
think we're so much superior which is
why i feel like our planet isn't
flourishing right now
if we were if we looked at ourselves and
like we are equal to animal
and not saying we could still eat them
animals eat animals
but if we are equal to plant
plant animal and ourselves this earth
would be flourishing
and so that's why i have a hard time at
times
but then there's so many beautiful
things that come out of the bible that
i'm like now this
is beautiful this is what we should be
living
but sometimes i feel like religion
concentrates on the parts that make you
feel like you're going to hell
and that to me is like uh i mean we're
human like
i had sex before marriage like i felt
like it taught me a lot about what i
wanted in marriage instead of making me
feel like i'm a sinner like instead it
i educated myself in a way and i i don't
want to feel guilty for that
you know yeah i mean you know it's kind
of almost like what we're dealing with
right now or it's
fear-based stuff yeah which is so
dangerous i mean
they they already off the bat say it
lowers like your immunity to live in
that fear state
but then the psychological effects when
we look at
you know i mean the things going on in
the world and how much fear is there i
mean
suicide numbers are up and there's all
kinds of other things that are going on
on a psychological level that emotional
level that are
super detrimental too and at the root of
it i mean one thing that i've never
did you grow up you grew up a christian
right you said
yeah so one of the aspects of religion
that so i didn't like i'm
i didn't go to church at all like my mom
would sing a little bedtime prayer or
say a bread temper and like now i lay me
down to sleep i prayed the lord
that was it like we didn't pray for food
we didn't go to church
um um but is this
aspect of it around shame
and guilt and like shame is a word
that's not even
like i don't feel shameful for anything
i've done because it would imply
that um and regret shame and regret and
guilt
like that i would want to change it and
i kind of feel like everything leads to
the next thing and so
yeah there's some bummer stuff that's
happened but it doesn't mean that i
would change it because it wouldn't it
would change where i
am now and so i think that that that
those words are just so big and they're
like the lowest frequency words that you
can
embody i 100 agree my sister and i
we kind of had a rough childhood um
there was a lot of things i was blessed
for with my childhood
but very rocky relationship with my
father and you know my dad
he admits it he was a drug user it was
um and it's hard to live with someone
like that and
it was just very a spotty relationship
and um and my sister and i have a book
called incomparable and we really went
in detail about it
and people ask me all the time would you
change that and i wouldn't
it really made me who i am today you
know like
was i envy of kids when i was young
because i i thought their homes were
perfect and i'm like oh
if i had a dad like that if i had a
family like that
i definitely did i had a lot of envy as
a kid over these families
and especially like my cousins with my
uncles i thought
they had such beautiful relationships
with their
fathers and i'm like i really wanted
that but then i got older
and i got this platform and i started to
realize like there's a lot of people
who went through what i did and i'm
lucky enough to have a voice
and tell people you're not alone and
that's what i started to realize with
the reality show and then with wwe
and nicole in our book is there's so
many people out there who had the same
upbringing as us
or you know my sister talked about being
raped twice
and had have gone through stuff that we
went through
and we get to use our voice to say
you're not alone and guess what
instead of being a victim you can be a
survivor because my sister and i kind of
looked at everything
in the face and really drop kicked it
out of our lives and we're like you know
what we're going to grow from this
and instead of feeling sorry for
ourselves we're going to make something
of it how did you do that
how did you know that's i mean people
love that victim and like people love
victim right again it's kind of like not
taking accountability
how did you get out of that you know i
don't know if it's
i've had thick skin as a kid so i hated
when people felt sorry for me
or i hated feeling sorry for myself
or i don't know if it's because i had a
twin sister so i always had someone who
had my back
and it's funny because i'm like of
course in life we were a tag team
because i feel like everything we've
done our whole lives has been a tag team
i mean even now
out of wwe i feel like we're still a tag
team and
um so i don't know if having been lucky
enough to have a twin
on this earth to fight through it all
and it was like
just a constant best friend or
constantly someone to say hey it's gonna
be okay let's do this together
um there was definitely days that would
be hard on me and then
she would be really strong and then help
me and then
days she felt weak i would be really
strong it always worked
out that way but i definitely got a
little taste of what it felt like to be
a survivor instead of a victim
and to me i was like oh this is better
this is what wonder woman feels like
it is the survivor and now i feel like i
can do anything yeah
and so and it's crazy because the minute
you could look at
life that way you really feel like
wonder woman like you feel like you can
accomplish anything
anything man that feels like um
have you ever i mean you've heard about
blue zones right where blue zones are
the
places on earth where people live the
longest
oh no i didn't hear this and one of the
things
about these areas is community
and so while you say just your sister
it's still the beginning of a community
and so it's some it's someone to help
take care of you
to look out for you and one of the
things this kind of actually makes me
think of another interview i did with um
a guy named zach bush and he was talking
about how cancer
starts and he was studying it and it was
a lack of cell communication
like a cell would go rogue and so he
used the analogy like this is where
you know you have a seven billion or
what is it out eight billion people in
the world
eight billion cell community and then
one splits off and that he used the
analogy of like a kid going into school
and
you know shooting people um and so that
one
cell went rogue and so they disconnect
from the community
and how important community is and so
this is an aspect of like religion that
could be beautiful because there's
community there
but then you have to i mean it's it's so
that that part of it is really good
there are beautiful aspects to it
um but what i'm hearing is like you had
your sister and so like at a young age
you know when you're embarrassed or um
shameful or um
you know you you don't you're not brave
enough to maybe reach out to somebody
like you had your
sister i feel like it speaks volumes
about
being able to have someone that you can
be truly
vulnerable with like my sister and i
always say this like what if we didn't
have each other
would we have accomplished what we did
or would we have given up at some point
because it was too painful
or too hard or too tough
i don't know i i maybe i would have like
and you know it's funny because people
are always like what is it like being a
twin i'm like what is it like being an
individual because
yeah i never experienced the first day
of school alone i had her
i never experienced my parents going out
and
being with alone with a babysitter i
always had her
all these moments that kids have to do
alone
and it's really actually hard on me as a
mom like when i dropped birdie off for
the first time at like
this daycare she i walked away and she's
screaming my name like just screaming
and crying and they're like just keep
walking just keep walking i'm like
crying i'm like oh my god i get to this
and i just thought to myself i just
dropped my daughter off in a room with
strangers she doesn't know anyone
like that's terrifying and i don't know
how to relate to her because that was
i never did that my mom actually said
when she'd drop us off nicole would walk
in like hey [ __ ] where's the kitchen
i need to play
and i would just sit there and cry so
hard but nicole would always come back
to get me
so nicole never cried but i always had
that comfort of
my sister in every situation so i wonder
if i was like majority on this planet
who was an individual
having to do it all alone would i be as
strong
i don't know i mean i like to think i
would be
but maybe my gift in this lifetime is
her and just having that strength and
because of that we've accomplished so
much and we haven't ended like her and i
like every day with our vision boards
we're like
how do we do world domination how do we
grow our empire like
you have to buy our hut my husband and
her fiance think we're crazy we'll buy
all these magazines and we're cutting
stuff out
and all my husband says is like you're
wasting trees i'm like it's my vision
board
um but like every day her and i
like manifest and go at it because we're
like we're 37
we've accomplished a lot but we're not
done yet like there's so much more we
want to do
and i mean it's funny because someone
when we were filming saw all our vision
boards they're like you're like the
kardashians you guys all love your
vision boards and i'm like i would be
interested to talk to them
because they must have a bunch of vision
boards too and you look where those
girls are at
and so when people laugh at my vision
boards i'm like well the kardashians may
know them
and so you might start going to the
store and get your magazines and put one
together because it could
i believe it really makes things happen
a hundred percent when i look back on my
phone and
i don't actually make vision boards i
should make vision boards i'm very
um imaginative so as soon as i
like something i start dreaming and
imagining what it would be like to
have it own it build it grow it whatever
like
but i think but vision because i know
that when i look on my phone and say
like i screenshot things i'm like oh i
want to build a
build a gym like this or i want to build
a garden or i want to do that and like i
look back at some of those photos and
i'm like
that's exactly what happened that's so
cool you would love it then
it's like arts and craft time and
my sister and i just will sit there and
get lost you know what it is we get lost
in our dreams
yeah you know and that's such a fun
could be more fun
right and just saying like her and i
will kick back when like okay
so do we want to live on a vineyard like
now
are we thinking more 10 years because
this is how we got to put our vision
boards together and
my grandmother she was she just visited
us like
a couple months ago um right before
christmas and
she was like i have to say it always
scared me with you two that you guys
would dream something and just go after
it like just go
and she's like i would always be so
nervous she's like but i look around and
see what you guys have accomplished
and it makes me giggle but she's like
i'm so proud of you two
like you and my sister and i are the
types too in front of people will say
really wild things i think it'll like
embarrass my husband at times
because i'll be like well one day and
he'll always like oh my gosh what is she
gonna say and i do say
outrageous things but i'm like whatever
i'm gonna try if i fail
oh well like at least i'm not gonna kick
back and say what if
i'm like against what if it's like i
tried i fail let's move on
but my sister and i really big at doing
that and my grandmother would always
kind of be like oh no
but she's like but you really have done
it and it's like yeah we have
and when's your birthday one um november
21st
so yeah
and i feel like my sister is a scorpio
well you came like 16 minutes after your
sister right
uh-huh very interesting sad just are so
like flip it with their comments they're
just so
like blah blah blah blah and they get
away with saying just about anything
because they're just so they
own it so much um scorpio is a totally
different vibe but
the fact that you're so cussed but
probably brings out the sag
um so i mean like obviously one of them
we connect on wine i mean we had dinner
in napa and i'm so
that you don't live in arizona because i
live in scottsdale and i'm like
we just missed each other so
how i mean like one of them for sure is
wine
why did you i have my answer for why i
started
making wine but what's your answer loved
it
yes right loved it i love drinking it
me too and you know what it was that
so my family they they were all farmers
growing up and still my italian side of
my family
they have a produce company called
majesty you'll see them like in whole
foods and
albertsons and raley's and safeway all
those different places and
um so i kind of agriculture was always
surrounded
around me so when i came to napa valley
for the first time
now i drank a lot of cheap wine in my
twenties and then i finally like
learned like what good wine was but i'm
gonna forget when i came to napa valley
i was like
holy moly this is heaven on earth like
i just i don't know what the energy is
here but it feels good
right and everyone's so nice and like
what i like is you might meet some
bougie people but they're
like down to earth and then you might
meet like these
really just straight-up farmers
and they're just hilarious and low-key
like everyone's vibe here everyone just
mixes it doesn't matter
what status you are whatever everyone's
equal here and
i just my sister and i became obsessed
so we started coming to napa all the
time
next you know we're here like four or
five times a year
and then we finally met ryan hill at
hill family estate
and we became really close friends and
he would get all these people to come in
and be like so the bellas drink here
and finally he was like do you guys
wanna a whine
and we're like ah it's uh literally
that's what we said it's on our vision
board but we didn't think this would be
possible until we're 50
and he's like let's make wine and we're
like yes
and so um nicole and i were just like we
can't believe it we're making good wine
because
this is my thing and i i feel bad for
some of the wine out there but my sister
and i like well we can't have a cheap
wine
and so we he did this whole wine tasting
for us so we're drinking it and we go oh
my gosh this is really good he's like
did you guys think i was gonna make you
bad wine or like well we don't know like
sometimes people
you know think like oh the wrestlers
will make him cheap wine
he's like no i know you guys are bougie
with your wine palettes
and nicole and i said like sometimes
we're looking right now
we're gonna do a project in france but
our wine is a little more expensive than
what people would like besides our rose
i think we did that good
but my sister and i are wine snobs i
have to drink my wine
i have to love it and how much is that
i'm curious what what is it
like because people might you know be
listening like oh it's just out of reach
i won't even ask but how much is it
because some people might
like i could do that yeah so my rv was
26 dollars we're sold we're actually
sold out of everything
but um so 26 dollars and then um
our red everything's under 50. so
yeah is the 35 to 50 mark um
i i think a lot of my fans wish it was
kind of under 20 dollars
and and i get that and we're actually
working with albert bisho in france
and we're going to do some stuff that we
can make under 20 dollars that
taste my sister and i actually flew out
to bone france
this was actually we both were pregnant
we didn't even know it it was last
november
i i was kind of a little bit of an evil
[ __ ] at times on the trip and now i
know why
i just remember i felt off and i was
like oh why am i just have like no
patience i'm in france
and i was did the wine taste different
you know
it actually didn't but i don't know if
just my body is used to it
it felt like i did get drunk quicker
though i did notice that and i'm like
this is
french wine like there's not usually not
as much alcohol
but we wouldn't taste it and my sister
and i fell in love
with the rose we fell in love with the
pinot noir a red blend
chardonnay i like french chardonnays
because they're more masculine
a lot of it and then when he told us the
price he could make it
i was like okay yay you know because
napa wine is expensive like it's an
honor to have napa wine because it is to
me the best in the world
but it is expensive but my sister and i
like listen
the bellas are bougie with their wine
it's the one thing i live super simple
but when it comes to my wine i spend
money
and i like good wine even if i have one
glass i'm like i'm gonna get a good
glass like my husband will be like your
wine your glass of wine costs more than
our meals and i'm like yeah
but that one glass i just i'm only
having one i just want to enjoy it
i went to uh went to a party yesterday
and um before the party went over to
a friend's house and so it was like
what are you gonna bring to the party
i'm like i always bring wine i don't
bring food i bring wine that's what i do
and so the fir but i brought a really
good bottle over to drink first to have
a glass of that first
um and i bought i brought a bottle of
bond over and i was like we'll start
here this is not a party favor because
it's like
really expensive that's what my sister
and i do though too
and like i we if we go places to where
people don't appreciate wine sometimes
we'll kind of hide it a little bit and
we'll be like i mean you don't care you
don't take the other stuff
because we're yeah yeah and you know my
sister's the type which is a little
embarrassing but sometimes she'll bring
her own stemware
because she's really like picky with
stemware that was me yesterday i was
like
um oh my gosh can i be a diva
and uh and get a glass because i don't
i don't drink wine out of plastic very
often like
maybe at the racetrack after like on a
night where it's like
who cares back in the day but right i
don't like to drink out of plastic or
of any kind even plastic like glasses
yeah like they taste different it tastes
way different
yes yeah oh my sister we'll be at a
restaurant and all of a sudden if our
wine's coming she'll be like
thick glass and i'm always like oh my
gosh because you know sometimes you'll
do the
like real thick and you're like i just
feel like it doesn't breathe
i'm like there's no way it's breathing
right now like also
it you know the glass is going to pull
some temperature out of it so i'm also
i'm a little bit of a diva
about the temperature too we do like
it to be cellar temperature so when a
bottle comes and you're like
oh yeah it's gonna taste a lot like
hotter or a lot it's more warm but more
like burn it's like yes
stellar temp kind of takes it and really
smooths the wine out
so between temperature of the bottle
glasses
yeah we're bougie we're bougie about our
minds
but i like it because for me it's it
makes it a fun experience
it's like every time we have wine
there's you know you're researching
you're looking
you're like ooh this sounds fun i wonder
what their story is and
then like my sister and i will sit there
and we taste we're like oh and
i don't know there's like this whole
thing to whine like that i'm just
obsessed with whether you're at a
restaurant or you're at someone's house
or wherever you're at
there's just something fun about it i
just love it i also love to do
tasting menus with wine pairings oh
really
do you do that ever well i mean i you
know so
the only time is when i've gone wine
tasting if they brought something out
but i've never actually gone somewhere
which would be
so have you gone to french laundry oh
yes
okay so last time i was at french
laundry was really i've been there twice
one time oh i was a little fuzzy which
i'm like this defeats the purpose why i
spend all this money and i can't
remember it
um and then one time i took my
grandmother and i do actually remember
them doing that
that was yeah we took my grandmother
even though my grandmother kept being
like more
food more food i'm like yeah there's
like 22 courses
yeah by like the sixth course i'm like
i'm so hungry are they going to bring me
food that's actually going to make me
full
and then they don't you just but you do
get full at the end but you realize you
have to go through 22 bites
yes yes exactly
um yeah i mean i just love napa i feel
like you're right there's a certain
spirit and energy and i think that it's
for me i really feel like it has to do
with nature you know it has to do with
orienting around farming and orienting
around
growing things and respecting the land
and the process and i feel like when
people finally go to napa
and do what i'm going to say honestly is
you should go and do private tastings
because you really learn so much more
it's anything that you walk up to and
stand at the bar it's great and all
and but they're it's it's less personal
and less informational
um as you learn that there's such a
curated process going on it's so
rare every year and um
which is why i don't ever like to waste
wine because you only make it that one
year that one time
very special but it's such a process and
there's so much that goes into it and i
think that that's why when people go to
napa and they experience that
they there's such a deeper integration
of of love
for the for what they're drinking which
is why with
wine it's all about the story right it's
all it's it really has to do with it
because you're connecting emotionally
through the story and through how it's
made and it makes then that makes it all
just sort of like a really special
experience but
i i mean even though i've you know had a
vineyard in napa valley i bought in 2000
actually i bought dirt in 2009 but
um but making wine i every time i go i
like to go to new places and even
yesterday when i was pulling wine to go
to the party i was like
that you know he was like do you wanna
you should bring maybe something that is
yours and i'm like
actually i bring a lot of other stuff
like i love drinking other people's wine
so
i'm the same way and that's so my sister
and i do this thing sister sunday but
we'll get a lot of just
very small family-owned farms
and like yesterday we pulled up but it
was like this house and i'm like huh
is that the tasting room and it was and
their small cute little vineyard
and they got hit a lot of their vineyard
went down in the fire
in the glass fire and but it was crazy
the tasting room
the house survived but um and some of
the vineyard
but what was neat yesterday was to go
through and like the wine was great
but to see the damage but to see how
they're rebuilding
and i think so my sister and i really
want to start sister sunday just so
people know like
the farmers are having a tough time in
that but it's like you know
that the fire destroyed so much but
i think people forget that these farmers
you don't
you know we both know in wine you don't
make great money in wine it takes a very
long time unless you're these big
companies coming in
spending 60 million dollars and you have
all this wine but
real good wine in these small vineyards
these people are just like blood sweat
and tears in it
and my sister and i are really trying to
shine light on these people to come
visit
and do these tastings because they
really got rocked in 2020
but to see what they're doing how
they're rebuilding
and to see like them working and how
much it takes i was just there yesterday
i'm like wow
but this is their lives and it's
incredible
and so it's been like a fun little thing
that we've been doing
but you know you were right in the
middle of the fire and because we were
in st
helena yesterday and it it's just you
know you're seeing growth but it's so
sad to see all the stuff that went down
oh yeah i mean it came through my whole
property
yeah i lost about it i lost a i lost
about 20
of my vineyard um but
could have lost it all um thank god they
thank god they cleaned the brush
the in between the rows and around the
edges before before the fire came
through
um because that saved a lot of the
vineyard it's
it's such a um it's such a process and
um i i you were mentioning your sister
sunday
and you know their spirituality is one
aspect but i feel like
the the door in kind of can be
through self-care because it's when you
start sort of taking care of yourself
and also then getting more in touch with
your emotions
or your needs or wants or
um just cultivating aspects of you that
are really only you
as you get to know yourself more than
you know that can lead to
you know a bigger sort of spiritual
exploration but
um what other things i mean how is
sister sunday going
and what other things do you guys do i
think i did i hear you get you always
after the new year there was an
agreement to have like three hours a day
like you get three hours of your own
sort of self-care whether it be maybe
groceries or
meditating right you get three hours
that sounds magical
yeah so my sister's doing that because
her you know artem
parenthood's been like tough on them to
figure out so they kind of started to
get that system
i'm lucky i have a nanny who comes
monday through friday and i need her
and my husband and i we're on baby
number two so he and i have always
had a really good schedule and figured
it out and
you know we had to do it with birdie
because he's still on the road wrestling
every week
but what happened is he started to
realize that
i did need a day where i didn't have to
think about being a mom
and i needed a day that he could be home
that could just be me being selfish for
a little bit because
i'm not that i give so much and
my sister and i came up with sister
sunday so it's a day and our guys always
know they always watch the kids like
there's no ifs ands or butts which is
such a
freedom to have and we get to literally
just be sisters and let loose and feel
young and youthful again
and i mean every week we'll like sit
there and pick ooh what winery or what
do we want to do this sunday even if
it's not a winery and
like just it's it's crazy because
mentally
and emotionally what it's done for me
it's just it makes you appreciate your
spouse more
your kids your life but it also just
gives you this little bit of youth that
just almost is like
i feel like a shot of refreshment that i
needed every week
so my sister and i we just but then we
wanted to use it too to help people of
course
my husband's like you can't just do it
for yourself and i'm like no i want to
help now all these farmers
and tell their stories but um it's
actually it's really nice
and you know a lot of people who
you know are first-time parents or even
having i've noticed
a lot of families are having a hard time
in covid whether it's homeschooling
or it's you know just being around your
spouse and your kids
all day long like we're not supposed to
do that and it's okay
like people i think will feel ashamed
that like why am i so annoyed at my
family
because you're with them 24 7. and
that's tough i mean my sister and i
we absolutely love each other but we
fight like we literally argue like these
old little italian women like
how peop my husband can't believe how
we'll speak to each other at times
but five minutes later we're okay and we
just realized that we're around each
other too much sometimes that like we
just get at each other but we love each
other
and i just feel in covid you have to
come up with a system
with your spouse you need each other to
be able to
break free and go do what each other
loves to do like my husband hates wine
tasting
so he's like why would i ever join you i
don't like it you and your sister love
it
and then he gets to go do his thing and
he loves working out
i'm always like working out like that's
your thing but he loves it he gets
lost in the gym and then with our kids
we know we have to take
turns and it just helps us be better
parents
and so i feel like sometimes parents
will like look at each other and be like
i'm waiting for my spouse to ask me
how i'm doing or for them to take the
kids it's like sometimes just ask them
be like hey let's sit down make a
schedule
i need a break you need a break let's
figure it out
and i feel like it's made brian our
marriage happy and just being better
parents
that's yeah when you were saying it
helps us be better parents i was
thinking
and also better partners like what are
what are some
things that you've learned about being a
better partner
you know i was really big on just um
i don't want to say that i'm controlling
because i really don't feel i'm not
that way but i just was like always was
felt like i needed to be in charge of
everything and just assume brian would
always just
tag along like almost he liked that i
was in charge because it meant he didn't
have to do it
but i did have to learn to like take a
step back and
be like this is the way he likes to do
things even though it's not
the way i like to it's part of i guess
compromise i learned compromise
and i think compromise was always hard
on me because having a twin sister i
always felt like i compromised my whole
life
like i've always had to share the
spotlight i've always had to share
everything with her so i think you asked
before this should you want me and my
sister on this interview yeah
and i was thinking yesterday i didn't
like clarify that but i also didn't ask
for anything different i was thinking to
myself
i don't know your sister yet i've only
met you so and also like
i bet it'd be nice to do an interview
sometimes where it's just you and it's
just your voice
i love being a bella twin but there's
also you know there's just a brie and
there is just a nicki and we are
different even though we are together so
it did feel good just to be able to like
me
like doing it i love it and that's the
thing with my marriage like sometimes my
husband's like i'm not married to you
and your sister
because sometimes he'll feel like he's
married to both of us
and that's also another thing i had to
learn to take a step back from is like
it has to be about brian and i
and not like three's company even though
he's like
so used to it and he's a gemini so he is
a sign of the twins yeah
so i feel like i'm like you're the sign
of the twins you get it and he's like i
don't even know what that means my
husband's really weird with horoscopes
so oh really oh yeah and i buy the books
and i'm always explaining like when he
does something i'm like
because you're gemini and he's like no
no it's not i'm like yes it is
um what's his moon do you know his sun
moon and rising
no i need to figure that out because i
just found out mine and i was like whoa
what is yours so saturn rising
and then um no so
sun is scorpio sun is scorpio
moon is oh gosh i don't know i have it
all written down
rise that your rising sign is not a
planet it'll be
maybe it was my birth time yeah you need
your birth time to figure out the rising
or the ascendant okay
okay i have it all written down so i
need to see because i talked to susan
miller the astrologist
so she was like breaking down my birth
chart which was incredible
and it was like spot it is it's
fascinating and you know
i went through a spell of going pretty
deep down
astrology route and um you know that
whole world
took a turn and crumbled um which is
fine um
but i ended up pulling away from it and
realizing
okay it's really good for a baseline
guidance like i know a lot about you
based on like a quick snapshot of your
chart and i can go
oh i know i can pull a few things from
it but to like live and die by it
and what the moon is for the next two
and a half days every two days
like all of a sudden you start getting
into manifestation qualities of like oh
it's gonna be in pisces i'm gonna be
emotional and it's like
you know you just can't it's not there's
you just kind of got to live your life
at some point in time but there are some
very
valuable nuggets and just knowing a
little bit about the chart so
right i got yeah like with the sag
like i can feel the sag that's why i was
asking what your sign was
right well and i'm i'm so like that
because sometimes my sister can get deep
into like the moons and i'm like
another new moon another this and that
and she'll be like well this this and
this and i'm like well wait a sec
i'm like there's definitely i think
times i feel like the retrogrades or
certain stuff like that but then there's
other times i'm like you just
you got to live a little bit and take
things with a grain of salt because
you know because i do see where things
aren't that
and i even said that you know my sister
and i are very big like when we
speak to healers and readers and all of
those we always take with a grain of
salt
because there's times where there's
stuff i'm like um i don't think so
but then there's stuff where i'm like
whoa i get enlightened and then i'm like
okay now that i'm taking with me
so i i'm always like with a grain of
salt i do it all and even like with
me it's like i know if anyone who ever
speaks with me
and not even spiritually just whatever
in life it's like just what i say like
my sister
talks to me like i'm her pediatrician
i'm like okay you have to take what i
say with a grain of salt because i'm not
a doctor
i'm like even though we have babies 22
hours apart and i
this is my second i'm like nicole i'm
not a doctor so
and she does she takes what i say with a
grain of salt and
i feel like i kind of have to do that
with everyone in life like we'll see
absolutely yeah because the human
element exists because we're human
yeah what are sort of the if you were to
put together
like a all of the practices that are the
most important to you whether it be like
i talk to an astrologer
once a year or once a month or i
meditate this much or i have sister
sunday
or i get my nails done like what what
would be
like the the group of things that you do
or you speak to
on a regular sort of like that you feel
like is in critical and important to
your self-care spiritual practice
so for me it's any time that i can
experience
stillness um i've and i really realized
that actually
through the pandemic whether it's i'm in
meditation or i now i'm a runner i've
been running it's crazy
or i'm out in nature or even if it's
wine tasting because there is a lot of
stillness and wine tasting when you're
way out there
but what i realized is when i'm in
complete stillness i feel like it's when
i can
hear myself the most of what i want
and what i want in present time not what
i want in 10 years or 20 years
what i want literally in present time
because i feel like i was such
a workaholic and i didn't realize it
before the pandemic it's just
i said yes to everything and i would
drag my little daughter with me we'd fly
everywhere
and i got my hands into everything
and then when the pandemic hit and being
forced to be home and being
still i started to actually realize like
whoa
i'm not the same bree i was 10 years ago
and i'm trying to keep up
and i felt like who am i now and i
started to realize i got to let go of
some of my companies and some of the
stuff i'm doing because
i'm just doing it i'm not really living
it and
i kind of was like okay brie like this
pandemic let's give ourselves permission
to grow
and evolve because you have evolved and
now i
really know i have to experience
stillness at some point in my day
i never know what my days are going to
be like this morning i woke up a little
late
buddies teething so my days started a
little rocky as you can tell and then i
forgot my carpets are getting clean all
this so here i'm in my bathroom
but i know at some point today i need to
just be still
and if it's meditation or if it's me
going running and hearing the birds
just i that's now i have to live my days
because it really allows me to
be more present present as a mom as a
wife and
just like what i want to do in my life
because i think i was just
too busy to really hear myself that i
was listening to everyone else
and i just i really was working way too
hard
self-care is not selfish yeah and see i
always would
feel like it was i think i i felt bad
when i'd go get a massage i almost felt
guilty and i'm like
and now i look at i'm like why like
actually i should have gotten more
massages now i've gotten a massage
forever and i'm like
yearning for one i'm like dying over
here by the way when you get massages
now it's like
wear your mask and then sometimes
there's shields and
like the whole world oh my god oh i was
getting adjusted the other day
because i've been having issues with
like my back and my
fingers and stuff and i had to wear my
mask and i'm face down and there was a
part of me i was like
i can't breathe i'm like this is like
because your face is all smurfs and then
i have this mask on and i was kind of
like wait can i come up for air i'm like
dying over here
it's like awful yeah yeah it's funny
they're trying to save you
to keep you breathing but yet while
you're doing the thing they tell you to
do you're like i can't breathe like
the worst is working out with it on oh
my god like i've done that a few times
like i just literally can't breathe
yeah i can't do that i think that's why
i took up running
luckily i'm out here in the country yeah
i'm running my
just my sister and i with vineyards and
so
um because i i can't work out with the
math so i'm just like you know what
if running if i'm gonna be a runner now
which i've actually lost quite a bit of
weight i was like okay
we need to run how far do i need to run
well so we started the 5k app have you
heard about this
so it's an app and every day they tell
you how to
like exactly how to run and by the end
of this you will be a 5k
runner and i will say my sister and
we've been doing it
and in the beginning it was super easy
you're kind of like
you almost want to run more but we've
been listening to the app
and then there was a couple days where
we were dying we were like
and then now yesterday or not yesterday
the day before we are like whoa
our endurance has really gotten better
so we're going to go today and i can't
wait because today will be a little
longer
and i i'm really anxious to see like you
know how this is but
supposedly after the end of this i can
walk out my door and go do a 5k like no
one's business
yeah so you'll be running for how long
do you run for like 20 30 minutes
yeah so right we're about um we're
almost at 30 minutes right now
so i think we're like at 24 or 25. it's
pretty crazy
yeah but i love it i feel so good is
there any
any other i mean that's a new that
sounds new is there anything else new
when it comes to the world of you know
interests whether it be
you know i mean shoot this could be like
anything is there anything on the
horizon that you're hoping for or
anything on the board
and on the board well so it's funny
because um
my sister and i we actually her and i
were talking about this yesterday and
you know we're wine has always been our
thing and so we're
we wanted to expand it but her and i
were also like
you know what other little things like
do we love like we feel like there's
something we need to do and
her and i have been kind of trying to
create shows where we're not in front of
the camera where we're behind the camera
we'll find these interesting stories and
then we'll like pitch them and be like
we feel like this will be great or that
and we've gotten denied a lot
and then there's some stuff that have
actually shown a lot of interest and
then months later they're like oh well
we'll go back to it we're like damn it
so we've actually been getting really
creative in those ways like
brainstorming
shows and even a lot in
more for us it's um more in reality
instead of like in the scripted world
and but just it's been really fun where
we're like should we have our own
production company because we keep doing
these pitches
so we kind of like have been doing that
and then
um her and i too like everyone keeps
asking us about makeup and
i'm like my sister and i love makeup but
we're very natural but then her and i
yesterday were like wait a sec
maybe people are yearning and because
it's been such a glam world
of the glam glam glam the contour maybe
like
people are thirsting for more going back
to that natural type
and maybe i don't know so her and i were
like yesterday drinking our wine being
like well maybe
we do something more like this which is
the opposite everyone else is doing but
maybe we have something there
you know it was sister sunday we're
drinking wine and we just started
spitballing so
well i'm sure and you know 18 months
when you have a
product line of you know makeup that's
like this like um
let's let's name it right now it'd be
like um
um bella something it would be like
i mean your wine is bonita bonita so i
feel like you need to
do something maybe yeah bella bonita or
yeah
bonita bella we'll mix our mexican
italian we've never mixed them
i always tell nicole i'm like you know
because you know we're the bella twins
which
we we did that because of our
grandfather is that your
is that the your real last name no
so our real last name is garcia colas
because my parents weren't married when
they had us or in italian they'll say
kalachi
so my poor sister still has the
hyphenated name
me being married it's danielson um
but we did bella because of my
grandfather
and because we when we started wrestling
he had just shortly passed
and so we just thought let's do our
italian side
and then but then for so long we're like
gosh we need to do something with our
mexican side too
and so then nicole and i finally with
the bonita bonita we feel like you know
for a mexican side
but we've never blended the two so maybe
we do makeup
look what we just came up with right i
love it
that's it i love it i love your
i love your vibe i love i love that you
i love that i have someone to go see a
napa now when i go no
um we need to do a little wine party and
do some wine tasting with each of our
wines
yes and we have to go hiking i've been
dying to go hiking here
i just have no one to go with right now
i love hiking
um can i butt in on a sister sunday yes
you know what we could do you know what
would be really fun is if we have a wine
party
even if it's just a couple of us and we
put paper bags over wines
and kind of just you know like what kind
of wine is this and we can all like
i did that one time a hundred years ago
when i was in napa and it was a
easter and we were up at dan costa's
house have you ever heard of dan
costa brown like or
a pinot noir um anyway it's it's a
really
really good one and um and he had all
the super fancy wine
and at one point in time they did that
with a bottle and i whittled it down and
it ended up being
it was like okay this is kind of tastes
old world not new world so i was like
maybe like france
yes and then i was like wow this is
pretty good i wonder if
like and i got to i was like i wonder if
this is like a rothschild like it's so
and they were like which one and then
they gave me a choice
or lafitte and i was like i feel like
i've had lafitte and i don't think that
i'm gonna go with mouton and i was right
oh my gosh that is awesome see i've
heard people do this before i've never
done it so
that could be our sister sunday okay
done
thank you so much yeah thank you you're
adorable
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button